breaking news lemonade a publicly traded
tech enabled insurance company has added
bitcoin to their balance sheet everyone
knows that microstrategy tesla square
and a whole host of bitcoin and crypto
native firms all have bitcoin in their
balance sheet but now we are starting to
seep into
non-bitcoin non-crypto type businesses
as you can see they have officially
confirmed that bitcoin is on the balance
sheet every public company is going to
do this what's fascinating to me about
lemonade though is that they're an
insurance company they spend a ton of
time being conservative thinking way out
into the future trying to underwrite
what is the risk in various investments
they make in various insurance contracts
they sign up for and obviously the
assets they hold on their balance sheet
and now we are seeing lemonade go ahead
and jump into the bitcoin world now it's
not a ton of money but still what we are
watching is that we are watching public
company executives whether they are the
business executives or the financial
executives wake up to the fact that
inflation is at six point eight percent
and if you're sitting there with lots of
cash on your balance sheet that is a big
problem your cash and your cash
equivalents are just being eaten away
the purchasing power is eroding right in
front of your eyes and so most companies
are likely going to take an approach
like lemonade is well i don't know if we
should do this or not but let's go ahead
and maybe start with a very small bit
can we start with something small and so
ultimately what we're seeing here is
part of their latest filing shows us
that they are starting to actually go
ahead and buy bitcoin on their balance
sheet now ultimately what i think is
very interesting is we're gonna have to
see do their competitors follow suit
this is an upstart here's their balance
sheet itself and so if you go ahead and
you look in 2020 at their cash it ends
up being about 571 million dollars that
growth of their cash has been 111
over the last year so that's their 2020
numbers but as you continue to look
through what they are doing
will they now be the crack in the armor
will a ton of other publicly traded
insurance companies start to follow suit
obviously it would be much easier if the
large insurance companies did it and
then the smaller ones followed suit but
to have one of the smaller ones do it
first and then to see do the big guys
respond or not i don't know but what i
do know is that every single public
company they have to have this
conversation what are we gonna do with
the cash on our balance sheet because it
is melting away 6.8 inflation is not a
joke and ultimately how are we going to
protect our shareholder value over the
long term bitcoin is ending up being a
solution for some but eventually i think
it'll be a solution for many what do we
think about lemonade if they have 571
million dollars of cash in their balance
sheet these are rough figures um if
right now they would have lost almost 40
million dollars in the last year alone
in purchasing power and purchasing power
just by inflation yeah they have to do
something they're running the bitcoin
tens of millions of dollars of
purchasing power being eroded away uh
and they don't have other investments so
if it's cash and cash equivalents the
cash equivalents aren't going to
actually provide enough of a return if
they're holding bonds or whatever uh in
order to be able to um you know account
for the high rates of inflation so what
do you end up doing is you basically get
to a point where you say look we can
either go further out on the risk curve
like let's go buy stable coins and then
earn high yield you know uh even if
you're earning six percent on stable
quench you're still losing inflation is
six point eight percent right and so
ultimately maybe you can find someone to
give you seven eight nine percent but
again the risk you take is the return
you get and so if you're taking tons of
risk then obviously you can get higher
return but you're taking more risk and
so you could also just buy bitcoin uh
which sounds like they're doing that now
what i do find interesting is they're
putting a very small uh amount into
bitcoin and over the last let's say um
uh kind of 18 months or so if you had
just put one or two percent of your
balance sheet in bitcoin it would have
prevented the erosion of your entire uh
uh balance sheet because bitcoin has
gone up so much right when it was down
at ten thousand dollars and then all of
a sudden it goes up from ten thousand
dollars to you know forty fifty sixty
thousand dollars that two percent let's
say you put two percent off the balance
sheet it goes up you know four hundred
percent that's eight percent growth so
it negates that six point eight percent
inflation so you don't have to do a lot
of it it's just simply saying that small
little investment we make is a risk
reward we're willing to take because if
bitcoin continues to do what it's done
over the last decade then it will
protect our entire balance which is
pretty cool yeah at this point though
shareholders have to be like if you were
holding that much cash in your balance
sheet in action it's almost bad action
right if you lose that much purchasing
power in a year you have to say you have
to do something whatever it is but you
just can't sit with cash i mean me
personally i don't sit with a lot of
cash in my bank account because i know
just get to wrote it away with
purchasing power